mesdames et messieurs bonjour ici paris
paris sous la pluie paris sous les
nuages mais heureusement les vannes du
ciel se sont enfermés depuis hier et
silk la chine il ne pleut pas en tous
les cas une journée grise la place de la
concorde
entouré de drapeaux tricolores
l'obélisque sur fond de ciel gris le
défilé du 14-juillet retrouve cette
année son cadre traditionnel
c'est autour de l'arc de triomphe que
sont massé des troupes que dans quelques
instants
le président de la république va passer
en revue avec le général mairie je
reviendrai là dessus tout à l'air et
c'est sur la partie basse des champs
elysées entre le rond-point et la
concorde qu aura lieu le défilé lui-même
vous voyez les deux grands bâtiments qui
flanquent que la rue royale
c'est à dire le ministère de la marine
et celui d'un très grand hôtel parisien
comme lambie la voie royale les champs
elysées juste à droite la place vient de
disparaître de l'écran
c est l emplacement de la statue de
brest où le 21 janvier 1793 louis saez
fut guillotiné le président est attendu
à l'angle de l'avenue friedland par le
général mairie rappelons que cette année
1981 marque le 100e anniversaire de la
célébration par la france du 14 juillet
la bastille se rendit au peuple de paris
en 1789
mais entre l'événement et la première
célébration officielle d'il ya cent ans
les républicains avaient dû livrer un
très long combat pour en imposer la
nation la tribune officielle l'épée la
tribune des personnalités officielles
devant nous dire vous voyez plusieurs
membres du gouvernement monsieur monory
de dos monsieur d'ornano il faudrait les
citer tous et j'aurais peur d'en oublier
si fait que vous les reconnaîtrez je
pense sens que j'ai besoin de les citer
monsieur bonnet tout de même qui va
serrer des mains
en fait au 19e siècle sous les régimes
personnel ce n'était pas la république
des régimes personnel comme l' empire la
restauration le second empire
ceux qui voulaient marquer la date
anniversaire de la prise de la bastille
été jugé dangereux et souvent il faut
bien dire mis en prison
les gouvernements de l'époque avait
moins d'indulgence que le gouvernement
que vous voyez sur votre écran la
bastille donc
rappelons-nous était tombé en 1989 la
tribune de la mairie de paris avec
monsieur chirac le voici qui parle avec
eux me semble-t-il
le doyen du corps diplomatique le nonce
du saint siège apostolique
l'ambassadeur de tunisie monsieur brook
l'ambassadeur la haute volta vice doyen
du corps diplomatique l'ambassadeur du
tonga avec des lunettes à côté de
l'ambassadeur d'union soviétique les
pays et en rangée les ambassadeurs et en
rangée par leur ordre de présentation de
lettres de créance à paris la bastille
était tombé en 1789 un an plus tard ce
fut le grand rassemblement non loin de
ce qui est maintenant l'arc de triomphe
c'est à dire au champ de mars pour la
fête de la fédération louis saez jura
fidélité à la constitution devant des
centaines de milliers de personnes
puis très vite et beaucoup plus vite
qu'on le croirait
le 14 juillet ne sera plus célébrés
napoléon devenu consul puis empereur
fille le maximum pour extirper l'idée
même du 14 juillet et il eût été
impensable qu'un drapeau tricolore
flotat même sous un autre édifice un
jour de 14 juillet d'abord parce que
l'arc de triomphe fut construit beaucoup
plus tard ouais si la marseillaise de
rudes
ensuite parce que je voulais dit pendant
tout le cours du xixème siècle la date
même du 14 juillet était détesté lorsque
les bourbons revinrent ni louis xviii
michard ghz dont le frère aîné louis
saez avait des destinées ne permirent
que l'on commémore à un événement dont
le souvenir était odieux pour eux voici
les ja de certains éléments de la 2e
division blindée nous aurons tout le
temps d'y revenir en détail tout à
l'heure lorsqu'il défileront pour en
revenir à l'histoire du 14 juillet
rappelons que celui philippe les
chaussures un peu plus facile
le roi des français étaient par certains
que p républicain mais la deuxième
république celle de 1848 ne donna pas
aux souvenirs révolutionnaire nouvelles
tentes donner la place qu'il méritait
puis sous napoléon iii la fête nationale
fixée au 15 août c'est à dire la date de
naissance de napoléon 1er son oncle en
1870 le second empire s'effondra dans la
défaite de sedan la république fut
proclamé avec un certain enthousiasme
mais d'unanimité elle n'était
qu'apparente
en fait la france profonde n'est pas du
tout acquise à ce moment là à la notion
de la république
la première république celle de 1792 et
la deuxième celle de 1848 n'avait pas la
cote
il faut bien de lire dans souvenir des
français je parle au plan général
le général mairie a accueilli le
président de la république le général
mairie a voulu mettre fin à partir du 20
juillet c'est à dire avant la limite
d'âge à ses fonctions de chef
d'état-major qu'il exerçait depuis cinq
ans ce général vendre mersch qui lui
succédera et le général mairie à de la
part du chef de l'état cette attention
exceptionnelle qui marque la dernière
prise d'armes à laquelle assiste le chef
d'état major des armées le président
giscard d'estaing a voulu en vain
l'honneur tout particulier à cet homme
au général mairie qui a servi l'état est
désormais ben ammar 41 ans et le général
la campagne me suis terre destin pas
dans la revue des troupes déployées
autour de l'arc de triomphe et aux
champs elysées thiam élèves de saint cyr
promotion 39,10 de l'amitié franco
britannique gerald mairie appartient à
l'armée blindée après 48 d'entre les
forces françaises de l'intérieur
arrêté en 44 les dépôts faits en alsace
ou combo struthof à bacau plus à chaud
après la guerre il bat en indochine et
en algérie
puis il commande une brigade mécanisée
en allemagne et une division blindée à
compiègne en 74 et chef de l'état major
particulier du président de la
république et il devient chef d'état
major des armées
en 1964 au poste il va quitter dans
quelques jours il va être remplacé par
les éléments que vous voyez les éléments
blindés que vous voyez déployé autour de
la
de l'arc de triomphe ce sont ceux de la
deuxième division de la vaisselle de
leclerc en 1940 le capitaine leclerc en
parler de l'appel de londres en juillet
le capitaine le ter se présentent au
général de gaulle en novembre le colonel
leclerc qui a rallié le cameroun la
france libre est nommé commandant
militaire du tchad avec les hommes qui
rassemble leclerc forme une colonne pour
montrer le plus tôt possible que la
france poursuit la lutte contre la kth
en janvier 41 c'est la prise de moore
joue le 1er mars la garnison italienne
de koufra se rend au prince livre et
c'est là que leclerc pendant ce fameux
sûrement nous ne nous arrêterons que
quand drapeau français flotte sera aussi
sur metz et strasbourg puis c'est la
conquête du fezzan à la fin de 42 après
que maréchal montgomery
le britannique a battu les forces au dax
devant et dalaman leclerc et ses hommes
feront leur jonction avec la viiie armée
britannique à tripoli
leclerc participe ensuite à la conquête
de la tunisie notamment en débordant la
ligne m'arrête
entre temps il avait fait une campagne
éclair de 3000km baldé afrique le 23
août 1943 la force leclerc devient la 2e
division blindée
l amalgame alors dans ses rangs des
anciens du fezzan et tunisie des
helvètes france d appeler d'afrique du
nord et des unités de l'armée d'afrique
équipé de matériel américain est
transporté en angleterre elle est
intégrée à la 3e armée américaine du
général patton et elle débarque sur la
plage que les américains appellent rang
utah beach et qui est une tâche du
cotentin et les hommes prennent dans
leurs mains le sable de la terre
française
en retrouvant ce pays pour lequel il
combattait le piscine
leclerc
devenu général il ya quelque temps déjà
m
image ou
on ne peut pas regarder sans
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
ce sens un serrement de coeur
pour les gens de ma génération et ceux
des générations antérieures
il y avait attendu si longtemps la
libération si longtemps plus de 15 cents
jours soudas vos ennemis ceux là on les
attendait comme jamais je crois messi ne
put attendu le 12 août la 2e db libéral
en sont le vans de la division faune sur
baby et nous suivions le kilomètre en
kilomètre de minute en minute l'avancée
de la division elle libérera paris le 25
dès le 24 soit d'ailleurs les chars de
leclerc sont devant l'autel de big ben
elle nettoie à paris
de l'occupation nazie leclerc reçoit la
reddition de von choltitz
paris brûle-t-il demande iter paris ne
brûle pas après quelques jours de remise
en condition la 2e division blindée
toujours sous les ordres de leclerc fait
mouvement vers l'est
le 7 septembre le 18 novembre perce des
positions allemandes à badonviller et
elle serait alors à travers vevo en
direction de strasbourg
libéré le 23 malgré la résistance
farouche il faut bien le dire des forces
allemandes et malgré le très très
mauvais temps le froid particulièrement
rigoureux dire que les mouvements de
leclerc qui prenait ses ordres de de
gaulle furent toujours apprécié par le
haut commandement allié serait exagéré
bien souvent reprochent à leclerc et à
de gaulle une certaine insubordination à
l'égard du commandement allié
mais que voulez vous les français en
terre de france font c'est sans trop
s'occuper de ce qui pouvait leur dire
leurs alliés et amis on libérera son
propre territoire
avec le même sentiment avec lequel on
libérerait un autre territoire
on est dans à strasbourg et à l'époque
portait encore fait en captant allemand
strasbourg
leclerc proclamera place kléber au cours
d'une prise d'armes sur cette belle
place kléber qui est le centre
de strasbourg habitants de strasbourg
avant cette pub gigantesque de quatre
années voici la place kléber mais les
derrière le général de gaulle
la flèche de votre cathédrale a été
notre obsession
nous avions juré d'y erbrée à nouveau
nos couleurs nationales c'est chose
faite
la flèche de la cathédrale
et puis c'est la bataille d'alsace et
puis encore c'est le nettoyage de la
poche de royan où les allemands resister
très fort formant de longs mois puis la
2e db riz le nid d'aigle d'hitler à
berchtesgaden en bavière le 2 mai 1945
cinq jours après le reich nazi capituler
et la france ici de gauche avec des
thèmes 111
fuck la france retrouvait au rang des
nations libres et victorieuse
nous retrouvons en direct sur ce fond de
drapeau tricolore flottant au vent léger
de ce 14 juillet nous retrouvons le chef
de l'état dans sa voiture de
commandement à côté de lui le général
mairie hockey demeure exceptionnelle est
ainsi rendu à 100 devant le peloton
motocycliste que nous aurons tout le
temps de détailler ensuite les champs
elysées que je sois sur des immeubles à
façade normal ou à façade comme on est
en train de nettoyer les champs elysées
son pic tesson parsemé de drapeaux
tricolores
je viens de parler de l'occupation
rappelons qu'en 1871 la france paie sous
la botte bruscaines elle élira une
assemblée nationale profondément
monarchiste le président de la
république qui succède à thiers le
maréchal de maintenant ne veut qu'une
chose réparée de lit du roi
on pense que le comte de chambord
petit-fils de charles vi va remonter sur
le trône de ses ancêtres mais ils
commettent une erreur à la place de ce
drapeau tricolore que vous voyez flotter
sur les champs elysées et qui est celui
de la france de napoléon il veut imposer
de drapeaux blancs de ses ancêtres en un
tournemain
cette question du drapeau change du tout
au tout de clients publics toutes les
élections partielles à partir de ce
moment là le montreront miracle la
france devient républicaine mcmahon
monarchiste à tous crins dissout
l'assemblée ce que depuis lui les chefs
d'état ne feront pas à d'exception du
de l'exemple de de bol il organise de
nouvelles élections
avec un seul but c'est que les
républicains soient vaincus mais mcmahon
président de la république s'est trompé
cette fois ci et nous sommes en 1877 et
une majorité franchement républicaine
léon gambetta cgri mcmahon doit se
soumettre ou se démettre le président de
la république maintenant on se démettra
jules grévy va le remplacer
c'est avec big 1 la marseillaise est
adoptée officiellement comme une menace
de mal la cavalerie de la garde
républicaine avec sa part et l'état va
lier sur leurs chevaux gris la
marseillaise disait j'ai d'adopter
officiellement comme hymne national
c'est à dire que l'on réactive le décret
de messidor an iii qui avait donné à la
mafia sa place il n'avait pour ainsi
dire jamais été appliquée ledit décret
au mois de mai 1881 benjamin raspail
fait adopter par l'assemblée des députés
une loi le jour de la fête nationale
française
c'est le 14 juillet on ne sera jamais
d'ailleurs père la loi est imprécise
l'atce s'il s'agit du 14 juillet 1789
avec la chute de la bastille ou bien du
14 juillet 1790 et de la fameuse fête de
la fédération ou 2016 avait juré
fidélité à la constitution nouvelle
l'ambiguïté n'a jamais été levé la loi
la loi raspail parle du 14 juillet sans
préciser la date
toujours est il que ceux de tpr juillet
1881 il ya cent ans après de longues
années de combat pour implanter la
république que jules grévy remis leur
drapeau au régiment et les grands
drapeaux les grands emblèmes bleu blanc
rouge que vous voyez au fête nationale
que vous voyez maintenant devant
lesquelles passe le président
ma république c'est les mêmes qu'en 1880
les drapeaux de jules grévy restaurée
quand il le faut mais il s'agit bien des
drapeaux du centenaire aujourd'hui cette
100e anniversaire du 14 juillet 1881 le
centième anniversaire du premier 14
juillet en peur pour être très précis on
devrait en des pales t1
lorsque le président de la république
sadi carnot l'un des prédécesseurs de
crédit d'un mystère destin suite
assassiné c'était tout à la fin de juin
et cette année là en des commandes à les
festivités car on était encore en plein
deuil national de toute manière 14
juillet 1881 14 juillet 1981 c'est le
premier centenaire de la célébration
officielle de la fête nationale de la
république française
le président a été accompagnée par la
marche joué par la fanfare de cavalerie
par la musique du 8e régiment de
transmissions au chant que va jouer la
musique de la légion étrangère
et qui sera repris à la musique du 5e
régiment la forme
la voie royale la boîte ni en aval comme
on l'appelle
réginal chute à l'entraînement aux
cadets france
son handicap il n'y avait là que des
chants et des marais en 1616 marie de
médicis et le cours la reine une longue
allée bordée d'arbres et partant des
tuileries suit la scène jusqu'à
l'actuelle tellement c'est la promenade
à la mode à l'époque pour les carrosses
en 1800 en 1667 le nôtre prolonge à la
tête terrible études reee toute la
plaine appelé grand tour sera planté
deux rangées d'arbres ses ombrages
prennent dans 1700 m
le nom de champs elysées en 1724 le type
d'emprunt directeur des jardins royaux
conduit la venue jusqu'à la butte
chaillot c'est à dire les poils actuel
table à charles de gaulle et son
successeur de nafi de mannini qui
possède une avenue à paris la pousse
jusqu'au pont de neuilly deux ans plus
tard soufflot pour atténuer la pente de
la voir on descend les champs elysées où
on démonte ce n'est pratiquement jamais
sauf dans la partie de très basse
un terrain plan et bien souffle aux
abbesses la butte de chaillot de plus de
cinq mètres et les déblais rejeté sur le
côté on produise un certain nombre de
rues dont le raidillon de la rue balzac
l'école
je n'ai rien d'autre thaçi
les colts
la musique hippie en régime off
la base aéronavale de landivisiau
les éléments de l'escadre de la
méditerranée
et quant aux autres le centre école de
ladite navale le groupement de fusiliers
marins commandos l'école de cuisine des
marins
nous les verrons des filets tout à
l'heure devant le président on dit la
revue du 14 juillet en réalité le chef
de l'état par tradition passe en revue
les troupes et ensuite les groupes
défilent devant le président parle
ensemble mardi la rue du 14 juillet on
devrais je crois plus de te dire
addictive et le groupement de fusiliers
marins commandos présentant des armes
sur fond de fontaine jaillissante
le rond-point l'école de maistrance
machine est apprenti mécanicien l'école
de maistrance mousse
l'école navale et l'école militaire de
la flotte
la légion étrangère 4e régiment étranger
ensuite le deuxième étranger
d'infanterie
plusieurs des régiments que le président
vient de passer en revue et qui
décideront tout à l'heure sont les
héritiers de ceux qui s'illustrèrent à
narvik en norvège il ya 40 ans nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
au cours d'un autre petit d'une autre
menu des votations film est fait pour
que celle que nous avons consacré tout à
l'heure à la 2e db le 2e régiment
étranger d'infanterie avec les petits
blancs
la musique de la légion étrangère joue
un flan au chat jusqu'à ce que le plan
arrive à la hauteur de vienne rcp
la 13e demi brigade de la légion
étrangère celle piscine du spa invite la
musique de la légion étrangère dont je
parle de piana sma et que vous entendiez
la section des pionniers de la légion
étrangère à la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris qui défilera
deux fois une fois pieds et une fois
derrière
est ce que nous appellerons son
appareillage le général mairie qui vous
regarde
la dernière prise d'armes rappelons si
vous êtes avec votre pied un instant
seulement un honneur exceptionnel lui ai
rendu par le chef de l'état le général
la mairie chef d'etat-major des armées
tu as la revue des troupes aux côtés du
président il quitte son poste sont au
poste et il va être remplacé par général
claude langrené le 9e régiment de
chasseurs parachutistes et maintenant
auchan devrait être reprise par la
musique du 5e régiment d'infanterie
toutes ces musiques étant réglé comme le
paquet du même 6ème bataillon de
chasseurs alpins les paierai derrière la
voiture de commandement
surtout ne désobliger pas les officiers
de l'armée française en parlant de
commandes cas c'est la voiture de thomas
si j'aime je serai derrière la
gendarmerie mobile ce groupement de
septembre aurait de versailles c'est
tout un monde ils sont 3000 à leurs
familles la musique du 5e régiment va
pas pris celle là même qui joue au chant
et qui continuera à jouer au champ
jusqu'à ce que le président de la
république dépasse l'école polytechnique
l'école militaire de strasbourg
strasbourg dont nous parlions avec
émotion il y un instant en rappelant la
fameuse prise d'armes de novembre 1944
présidée par leclerc l'école nationale
des sous-officiers d'activé que l'on
désigne dans la vie militaire par ses
initiales et n est ce qu a l'école des
officiers de réserve de couettes et d'un
il y a beaucoup de fichiers de réserve
le temps les armées françaises en
général et ils sont formés dans diverses
écoles l'école militaire du corps
technique et administratif l'école
militaire interarmes
l'école spéciale militaire
sur fond de durand palais
saint cyr les cavaliers de la garde qui
se place et en ce moment le président
passe devant l'école interarmées des
personnels militaires féminins l'école
du service de santé désormais et l'école
polytechnique le défilé va commencer
dans quelques minutes maintenant
une fois que le président aura été
accueillis par monsieur bart monsieur
bourges le général de barils générales
de vente au doigt
ce sera le défilé aérien
si le temps le permet et l'on me fait
signe à côté de manger un colonel de
l'armée de l'air qui dit oui il y aura
ce la patrouille de france et il y aura
les alphajet de la base de tours la
batterie de france et quand vous le
savez l'héritière des patrouilles
acrobatiques nationale elle est équipée
de neuf fouga magister qui ouvriront
donc le colonel de l'armée de l'air me
le confirme merci au colonel qui
ouvriront donc le défilé aérien en
formation d'art survenant les champs
elysées en direction de la concorde
c'est à dire vers l'endroit où sont les
tribunes qui entourent l'obélisque et lé
mettront elles
ils les mettront ces appareils
leurs fumigènes bleu blanc rouge et puis
ce sont les alphajet de la base de tours
produits en coopération entre
l'industrie aéronautique française et l
industrie nautique allemande comme ils
passeront très vite je voudrais vous
dire déjà de ces alphajet de la base de
tours qu'ils appartiennent à l'école de
chasse de la capitale de la touraine où
ils ont pour mission de spécialiser et
d'entraîner au combat des élèves pilotes
de l'armée de l'air et de la marine
l'école de chasse est équipé de ces
alphajet depuis moins d'un an
depuis la mi août 1979 le la voiture le
commandement rouler jusqu'à présent à 6
heures et devrait pour la dernière
minute rouler un peu plus vite la waci
semble-t-il ouassini l'illusion qu'ils
accélèrent elle devrait rouler à 12km
allèrent jusqu'au chevaux de marly elle
devrait être à 9h52
comme il est 9h51 30 l'horaire est
parfaitement respecté les tribunes
officielles commencent là sur la droite
de votre écran
le président répond en souriant et d'un
geste aimable de la main au salut des
personnes qui sont là et qui se lève
avec courtoisie une courtoisie normal
pour le voir passer
les honneurs au président il lui a salué
le drapeau du 1er régiment d'infanterie
de la garde républicaine un peu avant ou
peu après qu'il aura été accueilli par
le chef du gouvernement
le voici un support jeu ministre de la
défense le général de bari algérie
devant toi
le général de barry aurait dû
normalement se trouvait là oh là charles
de gaulle mais c'était ça a été le
général mairie pour des raisons que je
visite le président salue donc le
drapeau du 1er régiment maga
républicaine et cela va être la
marseillaise monsieur bourges en bonne
forme les gens mentent amaigri il vient
de passer de trois jours à l'hôpital
oh
m
ouais
la victoire ou la mort
revue du bataillon d'honneur du 1er
régiment rapport
la garde républicaine fait partie
intégrante de l'armée depuis la
restructuration il ya deux ans le 1er
régiment un effectif de 840 à peu près
officiers sous-officiers mission
l'exécution des services d'un arrêt de
sécurité pour le président de république
et éventuellement de prestige pour le
premier ministre le ministre de la
défense et les présidents des assemblées
parlementaires
son personnel est l'objet d'une
sélection sévère pour le physique la
présentation et la moyenne d'âge de ses
personnels et de 24 ans
des chevaliers de la pellicule autour du
président
il salue les mairies salles et
20 p
la soirée voici par exemple monsieur
bailly vice-président du sénat et
d'impressionnantes appétit
à nos jours dont marc du gouvernement
monsieur poèmes de chaban delmas
il
derrière le président monsieur alain
peyrefitte de l'académie française
bezos
oui
les fontaines renouvelée de celle de
rome oui
seuls les rappeler
quand l obélisque il provient des ruines
seaux métalliques histoire de j -p
désireux de se ménager l'appui de la
france
le free en 1800
un char 10 mais il n'arrive heures à
paris que quatre ans plus tard celui qui
ce sont quelques-uns de ses paradoxes de
l'histoire
race des clans
car la musique de l'air
la paf la pf la patrouille de france
avec ses 9 août un magistère en
formation d'art et avec émission vous
voyez le double gêne bleus blanc
m
altitude 100 m
et derrière ce bleu blanc rouge des
alphajet de la base de tout revenu en
coopération
franco allemand
je voulais dit
ce type de pareil depuis août 70
ce sont des amis en ville d'armentières
rappaz bruit dans cette lettre s'ils ont
présenté au public il
à l'exception de spécialistes ne les
connais pas un top
les troupes à pied sont commandées par
le général fiévet adjoint au général de
hummer militaire de paris 6300 sommes
des écoles des formations des trois
armées et de la gendarmerie
donc
le gouvernement semble être à peu près
au grand complet
derrière le général fiévet dans un
instant en bicorne tunique et avec
l'épée deux compagnies de l'école
polytechnique celle là même qui eût
permis ces élèves joffre foch
fayolle
des caps chefs d'état ou chefs de
l'exécutif
d'octroi cavaignac en 48
sadi carnot lebrun giscard d'estaing
sous cape
résidait rue décidé de
ainsi
et son pur d'anciens élèves
le général fiévet et puis derrière le
colonel perez job de thor la promotion
78 x c'est-à-dire des élèves de deuxième
année
créée à la fin du xviiie siècle l'école
reçu dans 1800 k-pop de napoléon son
statut militaire longtemps sur la
montagne sainte geneviève à paris xe est
à palaiseau
depuis 76 c'est un établissement public
ou 900 élèves répartis en trois
promotions reçoivent une formation
d'abord militaire puis général et
scientifique
la loi de 70 du 13 juillet veut qu'il
soit apte à occuper des emplois de haute
qualification ou de responsabilité à
caractère scientifique technique ou
économique
dans les corps civil et militaire de
l'êta et dans les services publics ainsi
que de façon plus générale dans
l'ensemble des activités de la nation
et
le général
j'ai reçu une offre ferme de sa mère qui
m'a dit qu'elle regarderait 6 avec
beaucoup d'émotion
la préparation de l'x nécessite deux ou
trois années d'études à braid bachot un
match derrière et en maths spéciale
matinale bicorne tunique et paie pour
les personnels masculin comme pour les
personnels réunis
la musique de troupes de marines jouent
la victoire ou la mort
les élèves français masculin ou féminin
de l'x serge en situation d'activité
pendant trois ans en qualité d'élève
officier de réserve puis d'inscrire
enfin d'officier de réserve et ceux qui
ne demandent pas de place dans les corps
de l'état à la sortie de l'x n'ayant pas
obtenu un tort de leur choix sont
astreints au remboursement les pratiques
varient paix sauf dans des cas précis
on salue du sabre
l'emblème 5
derrière
l'x
qui nous a salués à laquelle nous
rendons son salut nous allons voir deux
compagnies des écoles du service de
santé des armées
l'école de lyon et celle de bordeaux qui
assure la formation des médecins des
pharmaciens chimistes et les officiers
d'administration du service de santé
elles reçoivent aussi les élèves qui s'y
femina et les stagiaires étrange
suivent à l'université comme les civils
les courbes faculté de médecine les
études médicales font ces temps où les
études pharmaceutiques 5 mai en échange
des avantages que dans son camp sont ils
de me sentais c'est-à-dire sol logement
habillement nourriture ils s'engagent
d'observer ensuite au minimum 10 ans
dans la rue ils sont nommés officiers
l'ordre de l'arrêter et il était qu un
stage de guitare synthé naturiste pour
la marine val-de-grâce à paris par mes
pairs au centre de médecine aéronautique
de paris corps d'armée de l'air et s'ils
veulent aller comme coopérant outre-mer
ils suivent un enseignement spécial de
médecine tropicale à l'institut de
pathologie exotique de marseille
une plaque
et
et on va passer en se séparant des deux
tétées de l'obélisque andy qu'arrive
l'école interarmées les personnels
militaires féminins
un détachement des finances de vireux
drapeau que l'action 75 avec une
inscription guerre pop 45 indochine 45
elle est située cette école en calvados
entre qualité de vie surnom près de club
et il ya sept ans l'école réuni les
élèves trois armées elle assure la
formation communes initiales des élèves
sous-officiers des trois amis suivi une
formation spécialisée
d'année en année je dois dire que le
détachement de l'école interarmées les
personnels et hyper féminin des films de
mieux en mieux
le pas et martial la tenue bien coupé
l'oeil clair qui voit loin
les écoles de l'armée de terre est
d'abord la spéciale militaire de
saint-cyr de sortir mcmahon pétain de
gaulle gallieni lyautey prochaine est
prêt leclerc de la tri flowcath rare
c'est ce primairement le chapeau
c'est avec les gants blancs dont on
parle a tellement 1914 la partie
symbolique de latrines saint cyr le
quasar a été remis au saint cyrien pour
la première fois en 1855
lors de la visite à paris de la reine
victoria on a fait défiler le bayonne
saint cyr avec plumes et rouge et blanc
aux couleurs du prince albert son mari
le quasar est remis chaque année à la
fin de la période d'instruction aux
élèves de première année par les anciens
c'est pile cérémonie initiatique
quant à l'origine de ce quasar est bien
en 1855 arrivant à cazaux rare au jardin
des plantes un oiseau d'un mort a
produit avec plumage en forme de salt
d'horreur et comme leur plus maire de la
même forme
les saint cyriens
l'appelèrent gazeur ce sont des films de
coop
l'école militaire interarmées le peptide
en tête- par le général de gaulle en 61
sa devise
le travail pour loi l'honneur comme
guide alors que celle de l'école
spéciale militaire de saint cyr c'est
fait ils s'instruisent province l'école
forme les futurs officiers ici du corps
de six officiers
q qu'est ce qu'on fait
à leur sortie de l'école ils sont
insidieusement et vont suivre le même
stage d'un an dans une école de soyaux
moyenne d'âge la maison
il ya diverses écoles
dans les terres ouais
mon public pour les
pour la petite
d'artillerie sol air à nîmes 20
génie d'angers matériel bush
l'école militaire du corps technique et
administratif d'arriva répond top une
compagnie derrière son fanion
l'école est placée sous le signe
d'athéna déesse de la guerre et de la
sagesse sa vie ses armes à victoria pas
sic
autrement dit nouvellement intégrée dans
l'ensemble des écoles de coëtquidan
elle consacre la volonté du commandement
dessous des armes de service est le
pourcentage
de damier faut retenir et on me dit 40%
de notre pas aujourd'hui et si et si
au fur et à mesure que les images que
ces dames passent l'accroissement du
pourcentage
l'élève féminin augmente
à l'accroissement continu les 10
les et au 1er mai élèves officiers de
réserve d'infanterie
une centaine ils sont destinés à servir
dans les unités non mécanisée il sent
fort mais secrètes dans et est rattachée
à des classes du siège militaire de
saint-cyr ils sont équipés
c'est un nouveau fusil il est réalisé à
saint-etienne longueur 76 cm 3 4 200
portés 300 mètres cadence maximale 12
cents coups à la minute d'armes
individuelles automatique organisé pour
le tir à balle et pour le tir tendu ou
courbes des grenades
mais n est sera l'école nationale des
sous-officiers d'activé deux compagnies
l'école a été créé en 60 bassin maixent
l'école elle a présenté par deux
compagnies d'élèves arrivée à l'école et
à quelques points seulement et le
fadasse est également de refuser le tama
ceci revient différemment par un tireur
droitier ou gaucher
sa ligne de mire house de combat unique
et de ménager pour le tir venu
l'armée d'équipier et équipé pardon
l'amitié repliable dans l'utilisation en
tir couché améliore la précision du tir
est possible baïonnettes et je dois dire
que le famas que fonctionner par toutes
les températures de - 40 à plus 50
en cas de mobilisation de l'école
mettrait sur pied la 141e buses l'école
militaire de strasbourg
son commandant le drapeau et deux
compagnies créées par de la 145 elle
avait pour but de ma gamme et les cadres
issus des ffi et ceux de la première
armée française
c'est une école de formation qui prépare
aux concours semi directe de recrutement
les officiers d'armes et records
réalisant en cela une opération de
prison
ford intéressant
m
la musique va jouer le défilé de la
garde et ce sont les troupes de marine
qui vont aller jouer dès que ceci s'est
passé ceci semble mode rappelle ceux de
l'école militaire de strasbourg
la garde républicaine je vous en ai déjà
dit quelques mots
la voici l'imagerie populaire fait du
gardes républicains un personnage de
prestige qui dans les réceptions
officielles restent parfaitement
immobile un sensible au bruit et aux
projecteurs du verre
en fait ce sont des soldats rompus aux
techniques de commandos de parachutisme
de judo ou de ti la plus échangée
tunique plus courtes nombre de boutons
moins élevés tissus plus légers pantalon
à son pied à wingles est ce sont les
premiers représentants de la france que
découvre en descendant
non les chefs d'états les rois ils nous
rendent visite
les gab républicain bob d'en avoir
atteint la perfection dans la rue ici
devant
sommaire mais là ne s'arrête pas au
service ils doivent s'assurer la gare de
la sécurité quotidienne de l'elysée
l'état major particulier du président il
s'occupe également de la sécurité des
résidents obsessionnelle
l'instruction qui porte sur
l'entraînement physique et sportif est
prolongé par des séjours
dans les camps militaires et les
périodes de l'histoire était sans
travaux
avec vous d'instruction du passé la page
la gare et du week-end et a tenté un peu
la gendarmerie
prise dans les divers contacts des
guerres
leurs nouvelles épaulettes
et
la gendarmerie mobile drapeau deux
escadrons à petit du premier groupement
blindé stationné à ce prix
je regarde la femme arabe c'est avec
booth son homme le plus important de
gendarmerie france mais c'est surtout la
seule à posséder des engins blindés à
jour en mai 40 la mobile a participé est
d'à peu près
au sud de sedan opposé à la 10eme
panzers allemands d'être entièrement
détruite au fond cela constitue un 45
comme toute unité de gendarmerie mobile
le premier groupe membres
mission
d'ordre et de renforts
départ
classique
laquelle quatre gendarmes mobiles pour
espérant s'en détacher important
de plus les gendarmes mobiles pour ce
type d'enseignement ainsi deux escadrons
sur 8 à tour de rôle sont consacre des
instructions spécifiques
de l'armement blindés
je les dis hein ça paris avec leurs
familles cela fait presque une ville de
3000 personnes et biens publics en
quatre ans
la musique va changer c'est des grenades
du caucase par la musique de l'air au
moment où fins ses débuts de l'armée de
terre le 6ème bataillon de chasseurs
alpins murdoch chef de bord et trois
compagnies
le 6ème bca appartient la 27e john green
et comprend un millier d'âmes
mais il serait injuste de froid en
suivant l'image que nous aurons vu il ya
un instant que des chasseurs soit pas
exclusivement destiné à courir de
montagne
le chasseur est également un fin pinceau
invité par le bailleur
on m'a dit ah ici à sébastopol à
solferino
puis au moment de la première pied
marre marre donne 10 est à fois pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale les chefs sur
web and combattirent solo alors à la
déclaration de guerre il était en
manoeuvre dans le briançonnais
lorsque les allemands
ai-je la 27e demi brigade de chasseurs
jeunes pins puis envoyé au secours des
norvégiens
nous en reparlerons tout à l'air un peu
plus
des conditions de vie furent prévu la
ville damon d'ici
évacuation des blessures un créneau il
fallait combattre aspirant à jets après
des matchs 15 euros
se reforma après sa dissolution dans la
clandestinité
ici pas au lieu du languedoc de la
maurienne 128 en
le 9e régiment de chasseurs
parachutistes
je me tourne parfois d'autres gardent la
première et la troisième compagnie et la
compagnie d'éclairage et d'appui armé du
fusil famas
vous le reconnaissez maintenant vous
avez vu je voulais des faillites a l'air
de pin stationné à toulouse c'est un
régiment d'appeler ses services en
liberté
ce staff
3400 soir
deux cents jeunes rejoignent les roms
dès son incorporation
jeunes chasseurs parachutistes
8 au stage de semaine à l'école des
troupes aéroportées de pau
pas céder
demain serait surtout dans l'est
jean parisienne à marseille
ce sont tous des appelés et tous
volontaires parachutistes
une compagnie du régiment est
actuellement au liban au sein des forces
intérimaires
casque de pilote sous le bras le 1er
régiment d'hélicoptères de combat chef
de corps et un bar 120 fille si les
temps d'arrêt de la rue aujourd'hui et
porte l'inscription à gauche une paire
un petit 50 capes il dispose
d'hélicoptères gazelle alouette iii et
puma son travail se résume en panne
ni revoir vainqueur
sa mission est d' exécuter des actions
air aux mobiles pour des opérations des
grandes villes
et à l'échelon du port d'armé par
exemple il doit permettre de prendre et
de conserver l'initiative par des
interventions
la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
une compagnie à pied le 96 hommes
créée comme bataillon par napoléon
actuellement 6000 hommes répartis dans
l'est
capable sans popescu
je
il va être la sécurité de ville
une personne c'est-à-dire carrier la
couronne
à
la marche des mus par les troupes de
marine marine nationale avec une armée
de spécialistes d'aucune armée de
médecine
cette passe en date
r elle a dû créer de nombreuses écoles
pour former six coups sûrs
les élèves sont recrutés que peu voire
très jeunes afin d'être adapté le plus
tôt possible aux exigences de la main
d'abord ici une compagnie de
oui
samba
détachement des aspirants et même nos
secondes années qui défilent sous les
ordres du comme 2004 fenain
leur véhicule
à l'école navale on dit en 1830 barbecue
recrutés par concours de maths spé
cette commotion convaincu le marché
61e
être officiers de ma vie c'est d'avoir
la responsabilité comme de la vie
et l'officier marina des rabbit tic du
métier des heures
mais marin il appartient de la famile
des gens
et dans les crimes étaient ce matin
m
cela s'applique aussi à l'école
militaire de la flotte bourbon 79
ouverte sur ton
personnel de la marine reconnus aptes à
la casse
de plus
le drap rang que vous voulez boire leur
a été remis ici sur les champs-elysées
sarr président georges pompidou
le 14 juillet il ya neuf ans
les l'école de maistrance pont qui
permet de former les engagés qui se
destine à devenir rapidement officiers
mariniers dans les spécialités du pont
du nom du vaisseau armorique sur
lesquels l'école des mousses fuite en
baltique pendant 30 ans les deux écoles
king devant celle de dispense on voit en
as par école des mousses forme le groupe
armorique
l'école des mousses des faits
une compagnie 1 120 l'école des mousses
accueille chaque année deux sessions
d'environ 160 élèves le niveau place au
3e et demande est rentré et la scolarité
de deux mois et meilleur nous
soutenaient l'école de m
un dette
je
l'école de maistrance machine et l'école
des apprentis mécaniciens
l'école des fusiliers marins
en fait à lorient le commandant de
l'école est une compagnie de 120
le régiment blindé fusiliers marins que
constituerait plus de neuf équipes et en
grande bretagne car ici pas la campagne
les chargés de former le personnel
cuisinier et fusiliers commandos dans la
main
besoin pour les compagnies de protection
n'est pas sensible à thé
et pour un cadre élégant sony tv
recommandé
le groupement des fusiliers marins
commandos un plein en langage militaire
le goût fut mcg aux us
il est composé de quatre commandes ont
implanté à lorient et la commande aux
majors de combat basé à toulon il
perpétue la tradition des célèbres
pereybère plus comme avant ce trophée
qui est articulée en 5 comment vos
proies d'assaut 1 2 puis 1 de nageur de
fond
le centre école de l'aéronautique navale
implantaire rochefort et a pour mission
de former les personnels techniciens de
lèvres citigroup l'école des officiers
spécialisés d'énergie et verdict
l'école des mécaniciens vers nautique
des électroniciens de l'opic les
électroniciens des propos graves et le
formateur
le
l'école que l'on appelle le séant s'en
étonnerait le big navale pour marion
2000 élèves par an
la formation de l'esclave de la
méditerranée compagnie à 120 l'escadre
de la méditerranée basé à toulon en 3e
région militaire et commandé par
l'amiral de castelbajac la france qui
s'avère très bas
de la flotte comprenant échelles du
levant aujourd'hui ce cadre le cantique
et celle de la méditerranée
en 1976 le chef de l'état décidé de
renforcer les patrouilles
et le rééquilibrage des forces
conséquences
belgique de la méditerranée un pain de
crise fait de la france la troisième
puissance navale en mai après les états
unis et l'urss et la première puissance
libre
la base aéronautique navale de
landivisiau 350 hectares est mobilisé
c'est une compagnie de 120 tonnes
commandé par un capitaine de frégate
fille de post 14 elle est conçue pour
abriter et mettre en oeuvre des avions à
réaction des porte avions foch et
clemenceau
ces bâtiments ne sont pas de la mer
5 le guide nous avions et bim
de flottis l'assaut super et un bar une
petite exception plus d'air et une
petite reconnaissance du peuple
à
l'école de l'air cemaa point l'armée de
l'air qui passe sur la musique
sambre et meuse heures de l'école de
l'air fut créé en 1933 elle assure la
formation de crise il ajouté
des étudiants auprès des parois
les élèves autres la zone résidentielle
et durant trois ans
100 des cas province
42 terre-des-jeunes
certains frais avec toi rapport rosso et
ils ont reçu le baptême
le départ
il ya quelques jours nous
au vert passe
élèves masculins et féminins l'école
militaire de l'est
96 élèves de la promotion mauricie gala
il sent pas prêt à l'école buteur de
l'ére en septembre
dans ce décor l'armée de l'air offre aux
meilleures saisons
et devenir officier
la structure les bus du réseau tice
yedder officier mécanicien blair
oui c'est les bases de verre murano
nicole des élèves depuis ces réserves
n'ont jamais
le futur réserve de l'armée
m
la voici
ipass rappeler de drapeaux
120 dr du groupe
et avant la seconde guerre mondiale
et à bord bordeaux après kunar
aix-en-provence montluçon
l'école des élèves de peaches réserve
dans un an
les officiers de réserve de l'armée de
l'air
la boisson qui passe est grave les deux
drapeaux
121 r d pour prendre
croissance
et avant la seconde guerre mondiale à
bout
d'abord bordeaux avec une heure
aix-en-provence montluçon
du daknam gazon kanger piqué et depuis
dix ans elle était à evreux sur la base
aérienne 106 elle comporte trois escales
ans d'instruction
et assurerait formation du cabinet
et l'escadron le d'y aller vous ici
danger restait pour sa part mille
poissons
la base aérienne 102 de dijon-longvic
lnh moins 220 hommes de dijon longvic
que l'ont remis au sous-lieutenant
guynemer en mai 1916 le premier drapeau
de l'aviation française la 2e escadre de
chasse équipements pie ix vient
s'installer à dijon 1 49
les mystères 450 661 les mirage iii c
s'en suit les mirages droit et la 2e
escadre est une escadre de la force airs
d'une technique commission
l'interception
transformation sur nous
la base aérienne
jean est très grande les basses 500 y
croire
c'est près de trois minutes
sa vie
la base aérienne 112 dit marin la meslée
rens le drapeau est celui de la 30e
escadre de chasse décoré de la légion
d'honneur de la médaille militaire de
pierre 39 45 rue des ormeaux soviétique
alexandre
biais drapeau rouge et de la croix de la
libération le sous lieutenant
madame aider dans votre porte le nom là
sur 20 victoires
par l'adc halimi en baby et 45 en 1961
se sont installés
la 30e escadre de chasse
où est la 62e transport avec ceux morts
sa seule celle ci fut dissoute il ya
besoin et en 73
le premier mirage et grâce aux poseurs
la base aérienne 115 d'orange teriitahi
mesurer 1 juillet 39 av président du
conseil et doit renaître
en 63 l'escadron normandie niemen si
instable à la base trois années plus
tard lorsque arrive l'escadron de
bombardements stratégiques cévennes
la 5e escadre de chasse est installée là
depuis europe
la base aérienne sanguin
qui est parti de la quatrième région
avec sympa
oui
toujours orange qualité
et viennent maintenant les fusiliers
commandos de l'air présenté par le sous
groupement des fusiliers commandos de
lyme armée également du famas 5,56 sur
lequel maintenant vous savez qui c'est
le nouveau fusils de l'armée française
et ceux qui passent ce sont des
héritiers des premiers parachutistes
militaire sud 1937 et des héritiers
aussi du groupement des commandos
parachutistes qui n'attire en 1956 en
argent
avant que vienne la légion nous en amphi
de ma un rappel de ce que plus la vie il
y à 40 ans
la légion
qui est particulièrement bien représenté
dans ce décret
la musique nous en plaindre est à la
marque de la région est
m
si bien c'est bien son nom
les fjords norvégiens pouvant servir de
base à une note afférente
l'armée allemande débarqua dans
plusieurs ports en afrique car entre la
france et la grande-bretagne décidèrent
de même jour
devenir un met de la norvège la première
division degert de chasseurs commandé
par béthouart embarque à brest être
comprenait la légion étrangère et les
chasseurs
fallait s'opposer à la conquête du port
de narry principal débouché en norvège
des mines de fer suédoise de pipeline
elle atteignait les côtes norvégiennes
le 27 avril 40 à l'issue d'une traversée
defeat agitée
les chasseurs alpins progresser
une heure au sud d'amérique c'est très
haut dans une montagne couverte de neige
la légion elle débarque à agir vite sur
la rive nord du fleuve rhône alpes
ce furent de très durs combats et en
liaison avec les norvégiens et des
polonais les troupes françaises
chasseurs les allemands de la côte nord
du fleuve une afrique en avril mais
c'était tellement au nord de l'europe
que la neige devait encore là elle
n'avait rien pour surprendre le royaume
ce sera le 28 mai les légionnaires et
les chasseurs norvégiens débarque sur la
plage berne 7 et après le très violent
combat
ils enlèvent narvik aux allemands
les allemands allaient être repoussés
vers la frontière suédoise
malheureusement la situation en france
interdisait de chasseurs alpins
originaire d'achever leur victoire en
contraignant les allemands a capitulé il
rembarre caire en juin au début de juin
après avoir coupé pour plusieurs mois la
route du fer et nous retrouvons en
direct la légion étrangère
particulièrement bien représentés dans
ce défilé alors qu'il pleut avec les
personnalités présentes mais quand
imperméable
les pionniers de la légion étrangère
respect des traditions et ouvre la
marche ce privilège de préciser la
musique tient d'une ordonnance du xviiie
siècle de tabliers peigné rh sont une
survivance de la grande armée de
napoléon 1er où les pontonniers protéger
leurs corps d'un épais tablier de
crooner tablier de cuir dont h dans un
cri ce point est capital
g
au pas lent de l'algérie
la majorité de ces sommes sont étrangers
ils ont choisi de servir et corse
le chapeau chinois d'un instrument à
percussion là ce qui passait la musique
principale de la journée franges et les
queues de cheval qui ornent rappelle une
vieille coutume de l'islam adoptée par
le régime à barbe et d'afrique en
exposer répondu jeunes la queue de
cheval et celui la musique principale
des premiers étrangers stationnés au
bagne et défie le mécano vie si 80 des
exécutants
menus traditionnels en 1900 elle avait
informé un orchestre à cordes
qui jouissait d'une grande renommée le
chapeau chinois les pieds
la presse gm demi brigade de la légion
étrangère qui combattit à narvik nom de
nova le chef de corps et son agglo ces
800 hommes sont stationnés sur le
nouvelle étape la république de djibouti
je créé en février 40 sidi bel abbès et
participe à la prise de narvik puis
rejoignez ensuite pas plus du nord je
veux la libye l'egypte le levant la
tunisie l'italie et la libération avant
l'indochine et le tribunal le drapeau
pour les inscriptions de cameron
narvic karen m'assois bir-hakeim rome
colmar haution indochine voie de la
libération 35 votes guerre avec quatre
palmes à cuire les théories 4ème
médaille de la résistance avec rosette
pas de guerre mais origines avec terre
2e régiment étranger d'infanterie dans
les mille hommes sont stationnés à bali
faciaux et apporter le deuxième étranger
renforce également le détachement de la
légion étrangère à mayotte colonel
drapeau trois compagnies
il s'illustra lors de la campagne du
mexique en 1863 et surtout à la célèbre
effroyable bataille de camerone
il a été créé en 72 et depuis il a
renforcé les groupes stationnés à du
boutis lors des incidents de l'oeil
atteint et il a participé aux opérations
au tchad en 78 79 eur
oui
et
il
le quatrième étranger qui se battent
illégalement à narvik chef de corps
drapeau trois compagnies le régiment
d'instruction de la jirs et ranger créé
en 1920 au mac os
dissous après deuxième grande guerre il
veut la quitte en 1977 et de
castelnaudary
il est destiné à la formation et au
perfectionnement de tous les personnels
non officier de la légion étrangère
oui
et tandis que passe la légion sur le
pavé mouillé et luisant de pluie même de
la place de la concorde ex place oui 15
on entend par la fanfare de la cavalerie
de la garde des trop d'escort il s'agit
des troupes montées du 1er régiment de
cavalerie de la garde républicaine aux
ordres du colonel de bardot avec son
étendard et fanfare en tête les oies
souvenirs tandis que la légion va d'une
part royal
d'autre part sur le pont de la concorde
reçu par monsieur chaban delmas entre et
supporters le chef de l'état prenne
chaux-de-fonds ses cages du trench coat
mon dieu je voulais dire mon tour puis
naturellement le régime en compte 530
chevaux
le premier escadron monde d alsace de
même que l'as far far so foot et un
bélier qui sont les seuls à monter des
chevaux p la fanfare comprend 50
trompette aux ordres de l'adjudant-chef
complète majeur
regardez siège se trouvait ces taches
claires c'est baudrier clair ces casques
sur fond noir
bref on s'est un peu câble plus
530 chevaux un cheval est acheté à l'âge
de 3 ans par une commission composée
d'officiers dépérit nerfs doivent être
grand et avoir après 65 et 1 70 euro
être de caractère calme à voir le très
bon pied je parle du cheval et se
présenter les gamins dès son acquisition
un examen vétérinaire très complet et il
va réparer de saint germain en laye pour
y être instruite
il ne sera débours et que l'âge de 4 ans
est affecté dans un escadron à st
c'est là que le dressage sera vraiment
effectué l'animal s'habituera ou sur une
réserve et une révolution sur l'épave
est paris sera réformé d'ailleurs
africains se doit les chevaux le 2e
escadron son gré et c'est le troisième
sont soit des bruns soit les ongles le
régiment de cavalerie comprend des
slaves encore
et qu'après sa branche
samir escadron montée des à 12 ans les
ceux du 2e escadron son bep
et celui troisième soit bai brun soit
alezan brûlé
vous allez entendre la marge de la 2ème
db par les troupes de marine la 2e db
c'est à dire des hommes qui sont les
héritiers de ceux qui libérèrent temps
de contrer en france y compris paris ce
que nous accueillir à bras ouverts le
coeur battant et pourquoi ne pas le dire
les larmes aux yeux la 2e db qui va
défiler aux ordres du général noël du
père à qui la commande est d'ailleurs
toutes les troupes blindées motorisés
sont aux ordres de l'officier général
que je viens de nommer la 2ème db fut
créée et nous l'avons dit tout à l'heure
en afrique du nord en août 43 pour
libérer la france
elle était directement issues des
quelques hommes qui des 41
sous l'impulsion du colonel leclerc
avait décidé de répondre à l'appel de de
gaulle et de reprendre la lutte contre
l'envahisseur pendant deux ans avec des
moyens souvent dérisoires partant du
tchad au centre de l'afrique
après s'être emparés de koufra vous
prêter le serment légendaire de libérer
paris metz et strasbourg ils attaquèrent
sans relâche d'adversaires sur toute
l'étendue du fujian et combattant
tripolitaine et tunisie jusqu'à la
reddition de l'afrika korps unis à
d'autres unités
ces hommes de leclerc formeront la
deuxième division blindée 10 août la 2e
db recrée il y a un an à versailles lors
de l'anniversaire du général hoche à
nouvelle 2e db portent l'insigne fameux
qui unit la france à la croix de
lorraine
madame le président du parlement
européen
donc d'abord le général naël libre un
commandant la 2e db les attachés
militaires étrangers notamment chinois
tous les attachés militaires sont par
définition à l'étranger puisque chaque
pays renvoie dans son ambassade
entre autres à la pêche militer le
général donc
et une fois qu'il sera passée ne
devrions voir un escadron de samp
cycliste des légions de gendarmerie
d'île de france et du centre sur leur
bébé 67
leclerc
l'homme qui commandait la 2e db
aujourd'hui sous les ordres du général
de division duperrin elle rassemble sept
mille hommes
armande 2000 véhicules dont 500 blindés
et la 2e db est implantée à versailles
saint germain mais à peine d'amendé riz
olivet à rambouillet à s'être hissé le
fermement ce de trois heures
l'escadron 200 motards avec leur mission
prévenir éduquer enseigner et des
secours et réprimer tous sont formés à
fontainebleau en 12 semaines il attire
la maîtrise du pilotage des grosses
cylindrées et une bonne compétence
professionnelle de riquet pratique
j'ajoute de la formation au pilotage
très complète les exercices sans lieu
toujours avec deux motos unis pour la
route l'autre pour la piste
le 2e régiment de hussards le chef de
corps le drapeau et 12 à mx dispersé le
régiment de hussards bape de louis 15
puisqu'il fut formée par le groupe
esterhazy avec les volontaires endroit
ils se distinguent à valmy et avec le
général bugeaud tels que des indes et
les guitares l'an passé dans sa nouvelle
garnison de sourdun il devint le
régiment de reconnaissance de troisième
temps d'arrêt
il a été le premier régiment être doté
d'un mix disperser et il dispose aussi
de véhicules de l'avant blindé les dix
espions engendre connaissances pour
combat anti char à grande distance grâce
à des roues de grand diamètre et c'est
hydro jet
il a une grande mobilité se frotter un
tout terrain de plus il est amphibie le
roulé dans l'eau talent de 105 à très
grande vitesse montées rudoyé surtout
elle sa conduite de tir très moderne lui
assure ce que les militaires appellent
d'autres performances sur les objectifs
fixés mobile et il peut combattre de
jour comme de nuit
un escadron d'escadron d'éclairage du
visionnaire sans gagnant pape
inscriptions deuxième des mises en place
des essais devant leclerc il a repris
les traditions de l'escadron de
protection du maréchal leclerc
pendant la campagne de france et son
premier commandant fut le capitaine de
boissieu jambre de de gaulle et actuel
grand chancelier de la légion d'honneur
l'escadron est stationné à saint germain
rabais
il est équipé de jeep rasure abl jeep
milan de jeeps et les races et est de
type i try hausse
l'infanterie mécanisée 5e régiment
d'infanterie derrière de drapeaux 24
chars amx 13 et 22 à mx du terrain c'est
l'héritier des bandes de guyenne
présente la bataille de marignan sous
les ordres de baya est l'année de
l'entrée dans les caps à paris le
régiment pleinement de ma barre à la
révolution et à valmy soul empire à
wagram à l'éthique soupe durant la
première guerre par l'aisne à verdun et
sur l'autre depuis 64 des stationnés au
28 août
les 12 cents hommes du 5e régiment à
paris expose m x 13 s est sain
et bmx 13 90
le véhicule de transport de troupes et
de lui s'illuminant
sans plus parler technique disons que
cette unité est en mesure de mener sans
renforcement des actions pour préparer
et faciliter l'engagement de régiment de
chars et pour compléter leurs actions le
5e régiment d'infanterie de la 2e
division blindée
les bpa est nul
mais des petits voleurs de voitures tout
terrain
mx près
puis les chars canons de 90 mm
les mx et ses songes
les boissons
vu sylvain d'autres
mais
mais ces vitesses et sansan des missives
à pusher
si le sol sol anti char et vous voyez la
france hélas pas de l'arrêt devant le
petit écusson
le 6e régiment de marche du tchad
derrière l'étendard
le régiment de marche du tchad de
dizaines de 40 à 43 à la tête de ce
régiment de clair désorganiser les
forces de l' axe au cours de raids
motorisés menée depuis forlani sur son
emblème à son mari koufra faisait
subtiliser un alençon paris strasbourg
vers 10 heures le chef de corps 24 et
hynix pèse evans de mx tout terrain le
régiment et compagnon de la libération
et il a reçu du gouvernement des états
unis d'amérique la présidence unaids
high tech
rappelons que le régiment de la rue
tchad a combattu à mourjou visés
l'afrique ou fera ce qui va ensuite à
l'ensemble paris steve webster
ensuite un bataillon du régiment de
marche du tchad puis vie du général
leclerc en indochine aujourd'hui se
résume à stationner à montlhéry
il dispose vous le voyez de charef 13
équipes aient eux aussi de missiles
antichars et esponde ainsi que de
missiles milan de mortier de 120 me
m et de voitures bouder
l'ensemble de ses matériels compères
originaux mécanisée en général à celui
ci en particulier une grande polyvalence
dans leur action combat
et vous reconnaissez les essais 16
derrière son étendard le 6e régiment de
cuirassiers le 6e puis y stationner
olivet près d'orléans
un bien bel endroit par parenthèse pour
ceux qui aiment l'eau calme
la musique c'est joyeux trompette par la
musique de lèvres et le régiment et
d'amitié déficit lié à cheval de son
éminence créée par richelieu en mai 40
il participe à la campagne france
combative aux pays-bas dunkerque puis en
angleterre puis revint combattre en
france aujourd'hui ils disposent de
chars et l'extrême et le transport de
troupes m
ce char et mixtes rend pas une grande
efficacité du à son armement principal
140 105 mm tirant jusqu'à 3000 mètres
est dû aussi à son armement secondaire
j'entends par là un canon de 20 mm ou
une mitrailleuse
ce qui souligne la capacité de défense
entière
et cette puissance de feu est renforcée
par des btp auspices dans le canon de 20
mm et applaudir sur objectif de
restaurer par l'un des escadrons dans ce
3e escadre ans
il sert actuellement pour cent
iter un registre d'estaing fils du
président
des amx 30 avec leur canon
mambé soit 5
les droits de m
dans un un stand les vpp à mx 10 ans
filles
les voici
il s'agit toujours du 6e cuir
mais voilà les amplis
tout aurait sans doute de retrouver un
peu d'eau ici sur les champs elysées la
pluie devient plus bas
le 501e régiment de chars de combat
rappelons que c'est en avril 1917 132
charge mais drg attaque terre à
berry-au-bac et ce régiment qui lévite
devant vous et d'édifier du 501e
régiment d'artillerie d'assaut et à la
fin de la première guerre et qui
participe à hauteur de la grande
bataille en 1918
pendant la seconde le régime a participé
à la campagne de france
il combattit en norvège en syrie puis au
sein de 2e division blindée
il combattit donc aussi bien en norvège
qu'au sein de deuxième division bas b
c'est-à-dire qu'ils représentent
aujourd'hui vraiment le symbole de ce
qu'a voulu signifier ce défilé c'est à
dire d'une part des anciens combattants
marvic d'autre part ceux de la 2e db il
a 40 à mx 30 et 12 à mx 10 p
campé par leur chef de choeur locaux
l'homme derrière battu marc les tabacs
les performances tout terrain de ce char
et x30 la dotation en équipements de
vision
lui permet de poursuivre le combat
après deux jeux d'éveil mais à un rythme
moindre je suppose qu'elle joue
c'est la musique de l'air qui joyeux
trempette
et
je pense envoyant ses chars de la 2ème
db est ce bien faire vos papilles en
quarante classes
je me trouvais un peu plus haut sur les
champs
à bali
et je voyais un an
ce fut sans doute
pas
j'allais dire le plus
sur ce plan-là sûr
nos revenus en vue
il a mis en scène la 2e db
en vrai si
nous leur offrions tout ce que l'on
voulait pas de prix car ils nous avaient
peu vers la liberté
je pense que c'est personnel
et le look pas et je sais enfin je
suppose que je dise
ils se souviennent peu de tout ce qu'on
leur a raconté sur la libération arabe
vtt et mixant fait plier le dtn x 10 ans
qui vit avec leur clientèle en 20009
la pluie redouble de violence comme
disent les bons jeux terre
mais il en faut plus pour gêner les
artilleurs voici le premier région
arctique marine chef de corps et un bar
câpres vpp câpres rat pack je vous dirai
ensuite ce que c'est et ce premier
joueur thierry de marine est l'héritier
des compagnies ordinaire de la marine
ray 1 16 120 m2 par le cardinal de
richelieu
après le dernier conflit ou du moins il
veut y fut dissous en 1940 et il devint
ensuite le 1er régiment d'artillerie des
forces françaises libres des ffl et il
combattit partout et de tous les combats
y est madame anne paquereau mal geri by
anonyme a dit le débarquement en
provence le 15 août terme 4 colmar
strasbourg
il est maintenant maman déry de thé 1977
alors ils disposent de came en août au
mouvement de 155 mm qui peuvent tirer à
20km la cadence au proto minutes de rab
art de tirs d'artillerie de campagne
ra d'artillerie de campagne en abrégé
rat pack est râpé assez rattaque et de
radars ne pas comprendre radar attaque
météorologiques scirocco
dans son organisation actuelle le 1er
régiment d'artillerie de marine peut en
deux minutes neutralisé trois hectares
canon autour de 155 millions
le 5e régiment mme jean chef de corps
drapeau lui véhicules de combat et
quatre poteaux moteur chez toi
la mission du génie et bien ma foi et
des deux ordres facilité pour vendre ses
propres unités et entravaient les
mouvements ennemis
le 5e régiment de génie fut créée sous
les ordres du colonel joffre futur
maréchal de france et peluches quid de
la construction et d'exploitation des
chemins de fer en france et outre-mer
pendant la première guerre mondiale il
remis en état les communications
ferroviaires
il participe à la seconde guerre
mondiale puis rétabli le réseau de voies
ferrées en france et en allemagne il
remis en condition des voies ferrées en
indochine est il mis en oeuvre l'épreuve
l'inde et les 13 cents heures de ce
cinquième génie utilise des matériaux
très variés véhicules de combat du génie
gillois excavateur retranché voser
bavure de voies ferrées locotracteur en
spam etc dont un spécialement de
véhicules de combat du génie dérivé de
la première liste rampe est équipé d'une
pelle d'un feuillet d'un brave travail
et puis ses promoteurs le pea le poteau
moteur d'accompagnement capable de
lancer ses faveurs de 20 mètres de
portée et permettant c'est très dur de
faire passer des jarrets mx tente
c'est la musique que principal des
troupes de marine qui joue
le deuxième régiment de commandement et
de soutien créé dès 1871 d'april part
active au combat le 14 18 puis en 39-40
avec antenne de france et la coupe
d'allemagne en 44 avec la 2e division
blindée de leclerc
après avoir été la base arrière de la 2e
db il disparaîtra et sera recréée en
juillet 1979 la vente un an
nous ne l'avons jamais vu défiler il est
maintenant stationnaire satirique
alors ces mille officiers sous-officiers
et hommes de rang utilisent du matériel
varié
la moto est 6,8 de vouvoyer les orateurs
impressions des porte chars des plaisirs
de la première de ces missions est de
fournir à la division des moyens de
transmission et de vie nécessaires au
commandement de cette unité est la
deuxième mission chez le soutien
puisqu'il est de reconnaissance de
thomas - soutien parents soutenir ce
devait ravitailler recompléter réparer
et aux besoins électriques
ça c'est des transmissions
après demi nous allons voir le 54e
régiment d'artillerie celui qui semences
n'a pas au loin mais c'est toujours le
régiment de commandement et de soutien
qui passe
les hommes imperturbable sous de la
pluie
le régime invertir x 5 ans quatrième
dans le personnel et en combinaison de
chars avec foulards barbe
le voici là bas qui s'annonce il est
représenté par dvd paix et des relents
et cette année en juin il a effectué son
premier tir de missile roland au centre
d'essais de biscarrosse face à
l'évolution et à l'ific et à
l'efficacité des avions actuels les
régiments sol air sont équipés de
matériel de plus en plus moderne en
équipant 54e de retirer avec le système
de roland le commandement veux qu'ils
participent à des défenses
anti-aériennes les unités blindées et
mécanisé du premier cobaye chaque tapis
de relance comprend deux sections d'urs
fischer et chaque pièce à deux équipes
de tir constituées chacune de trois
hommes de chez pepsico cointet
retirèrent et indique-t-elle
le système roland que vous voyez si vos
yeux sur l'écran
est destinée en fait la défense contre
avions venant tabac ce très basse
altitude
le rolland est applicable contre toutes
les cibles dans les vitesses vont
jusqu'à mach 1 avec 3 il est capable de
combattre en notre consoeur contaminés
et il peut traverser des gains de plus
d'un mètre cinquante de profondeur
le principe de tille de ces
appareillages est simple en 25 pour ceux
qui sablent mettre en oeuvre grâce à un
radar de surveillance vous le voyez
tournée dont la portée depuis le 15 km
et grâce à un ensemble optiques
électroniques de l'avion va l'aéronef en
général de détecter identifier et le
tireur déclenché ensuite le feu lorsque
la cible et comment dirais-je à bonne
distance
alors pour s'adapter à ce nouveau
matériel le 54e d'artillerie a dû mener
à bonne fin de recyclage de ces
personnels et la formation des applis
qui tiennent à l'intérieur des équipes
tirent des postes clés on considère au
premier port d'armé de la formation des
cadres phv il faut souligner que
l'efficacité de ces systèmes rolland et
tout à payer la valeur des personnels et
le mettre en veille
actuellement tous les matériels de tp tu
es les personnels ont été instruits
l'escadron de missiles sol air de
luxeuil
un escadron de défense aérienne c'est le
quatrième d'une série de douze escadron
de défense sol air en cours de mise en
place dans l'armée de l'air
l'ogbl il a pour mission d'assurer la
défense abbas est très basse altitude
des terrains de luxeuil où sont
stationnés les unitaires bien à
caractère nucléaire et il est équipé
vaudoyer de systèmes crotales conçu pour
permettre la destruction des aéronefs
évoluant dans la solitude et à des
vitesses supersoniques
quelles que soient les conditions
météorologiques il est donc parfaitement
à l'aise aujourd'hui
l'escadron se compose de deux sections
ayant chacune l'unité d'acquisition avec
un radar de veille et un système
d'exploitation des informations assurant
la surveillance de l'espace et et
d'unité de tirs avec un radar de
poursuites et caetera et caetera et une
tour est de 86
il est trop tard
et derrière des bitubes de 20 mm
les voici
appartenant toujours à l'esca banc de
missiles sol air de luxe m et puis la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
que l'on revoit alors avec divers
équipements le fourgon pompe tonne léger
le fourgon pompe tonne le fourgon mixte
à haute pression
labat terminant le parcours des jardins
de marigny indique que l'escadron des
missiles sol-air buxeuil est passé
maintenant
et à appeler de plus officiel de fins
s'il vous plaît
les sapeurs pompiers donc
faux bond pompe-tonne dg victime d'un
incendie mais une réserve d'eau de 600
avis invite le transport par le
personnel et le matériel nécessaire pour
combattre les feux effectué les
sauvetages et toutes les opérations
qu'un conte sapeurs-pompiers le
faux-bond pompe tonne me suis un petit
peu plus loin
le fonds mixtes tracts zodiac
et quand vous verrez les zodiac vous
verrez à leur bord les plongeurs et les
spécialistes d'intervention subaquatique
qu'ils effectuent des recherches en
scène par les canaux de la région
parisienne et dans des soupes les mâles
peu
les échecs qui votent pas automatique
le losc annonce visible était si les
états
les fourgons de grande puissance des
mythes war le lancement ni pauvre mort
table un camion grue et un ventilateur
en débit tout ceci est extrêmement
technique qui toi qu'un jour nous
demandions à la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris de faire une
émission spéciale avec elle pour mieux
familiariser le public avec des
matériels la revue le défilé se
terminent chaque année des personnels
ayant dépité le 14 juillet sont invités
à déjeuner par deux municipalités de
paris et par un certain nombre
d'associations
au total 2000 invitations reçues cette
année là l'amérique paris sous la
présidence de monsieur chirac à milliers
de visites sous-officiers et hommes du
rang sont à déjeuner versement de scènes
de vie dans avant-hier les anciens de la
2e db sous la présidence de la région
leclerc ont reçu 200 invitations les
anciens bras et danube ce la présidence
de dollars et celle de l'atr-72
invitation et puis elle est ancien
légionnaire et ancien chasseur les
anciens marins
l'union nationale des parachutistes et
combattant volontaire de la résistance
le président de la république félicite
et remercie le général de corps d'armée
de bérigaud herbert winter de peine et
puis il ya une dizaine d'autres
associations et fédérations qui ont
demandé à ceux qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui de venir prendre un repas
avec eux et le son côté l'armée de l'air
a organisé deux grands rassemblements
sur les bases du bourget et de saisir
pour 500 auditeurs et auquel sont
invités les membres des associations
d'anciens obligataire président serre la
main à monsieur d'ornano à madame
pelletier monsieur chartier un cheveu le
cap à monsieur soit sans qu'on aperçoit
à monsieur de new
à tous les membres du gouvernement voici
maintenant chez chaban delmas président
va sembler monsieur peyrefitte monsieur
bonnet madame sa nécessité le ministre
de l'industrie toujours reconnaissable à
ses cheveux gris et son air souriant
là le défilé devait se terminer à dix
nous sommes comme les militaires pile à
l'heure le maire de paris salue le
président de la république
d'autres personnalités enfants tout le
temps
le nom du saint siège apostolique doyen
le roi du corps diplomatique à paris
et puis là sans parapluie juste à côté
du président monsieur mairie mais le
patron des services du protocole et les
parapluies les parapluies les parapluies
que voulez vous je peigne atos qui
l'avait sauvé ses lunettes
tu pas sur des oeufs
quelqu'un qui lui ressemble
et puis et les ambassadeurs les chefs de
mission diplomatique dans un instant si
le président continue n'arrivera avait
prévu une des attachés militaires
ça a été une belle revue un beau défilé
gâcher il faut bien le dire un peu par
le temps mais que voulez-vous me vivant
dans le nord du pays
un été pourri comme l'on dit ce n'est
pas cela qui va empêcher les éléments de
l'armée française de défiler pour le 14
juillet
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit nous vous
l'avons rappelé du 14 juillet du
centenaire puisque c'est il y as enfin
mai 14 juillet 1881 que ce léger et sous
le président jules grévy la marseillaise
suite adopté officiellement comme hymne
national c'est à dire que non réactive à
le décret de messidor an iii qui
amènerait marseillaise sa place mais qui
n'avait pour ainsi dire jamais été
appliquée et c'est au mois de mai 1881
alors que la république est fait ce
ballet depuis 70 ans master d'italie et
plusieurs seti un seder monaco ancien
préfet au mois de mai 1880 benjamin
raspail qui a tout fait pour lui à la
barre y fit adopter la loi
le jour de la fête nationale française
du 14 juillet quel que soit le temps le
président de la république va quitter
avec gerald de montauban
la place de la concorde livrant ses
impressions l'avait supprimée mais nous
n'avons pas de micros qui suit le
président est parfaitement souriant le
chef de l'état et le chef du
gouvernement
aussi souriant l'un que l'autre et
monsieur bourges a l'air
particulièrement satisfaits de ce que
nous appellerons la prestation de
l'armée c'est le ministre de la défense
c'est être
reportage à paris en direct de jean
claude delannoy tête avec le président
repart nous allons rendre l'antenne un
autre studio à cognac jay les
commentaires étaient de léon zitrone
bien bénéficier devrait le remercier de
l'aimable concours dit le chef de
bataillon fromion de léguer par le
service d'information et de relations
publiques des armées ceux qui bien
souvent nous a montré ce qu'il fallait
souligner ici paris la concorde
l'étoile l'arc de triomphe le drapeau
tricolore à vous cognacq jay